they're shocking new fallout in the
scandal surrounding Megan markle's BFF
Jessica Mulrooney's husband has just
quit his job I have decided to
immediately step away from my role as
anchor e talk to create space for a new
perspective and a new voice known as the
Ryan Seacrest of Canada Ben is leaving
his 18 year gig after Jessica got
embroiled in a war of words with
Instagram influencer Sasha Exeter her
best friend is arguably one of the most
famous black women in the world I love
my wife
however it is not my place to speak for
her and today together we are committed
to doing the work to both learn and
understand more about anti black racism
et has learned megan is taking a step
back in distancing herself from Jessica
after she made unacceptable and
offensive comments
we're told Megan's friends have been
quote concerned for some time that
jessica has been profiting from her
relationship with Megan and using it to
further her brand meanwhile a source
reports Megan and Harry spent a quiet
Father's Day with Archie in LA as for
Prince William well here are the
adorable new photos of the prince and
his three kids that duchess Kate took to
celebrate both fathers dank and Williams
38th birthday all three children are
casually dressed in shorts and here's a
royal easter egg
that swing is a nod to Prince Charles
who gave it to William and Kate as a
wedding present
[Music]